609 on your monday morning so even after
the wind that we're talking about after
that's gone in a day or two it is still
going to feel drafty around part of the
las vegas trip of course now we're
talking about the nfl draft now that
event itself is still more than two
weeks away however drivers at flamingo
and las vegas boulevard you're going to
see lanes coned off starting this
wednesday scheduled to run for two weeks
so here's the deal you're going to be
losing the far right turn lane from
eastbound flamingo to go south on las
vegas boulevard also from six in the
morning until five in the afternoon
they're going to take away that second
turn lane now for drivers who are
southbound on las vegas boulevard
they're taking away the two right lanes
from flamingo down to the main bellagio
entrance and again from six in the
morning till five in the evening they're
going to take away the third right
southbound lane this is also crews can
build that red carpet stage over the
bellagio fountains for the draft full
road closures that's not going to happen
until we get closer to draft day now all
of this info and everything about the
draft is on eight newsnow dot com there
we go buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone something driving
you crazy email me traffic eight at
eight newsnow dot com